what on Earth has been going on the last
few weeks
so it really what's been going on it
started with the Chinese balloon it was
obviously a spy balloon we shot it down
and the discussion uh or not then there
were the three other objects and events
um that appeared in the subsequent weeks
after that those were most likely uh
just civilian drones balloons or perhaps
something we had that was classified
they were not extraterrestrial Vehicles
Etc and so on now the part of it that's
very suspicious
is that all of that happened within
about a week of me escorting the first
top secret witness into DC to provide
testimony about what he knows about this
issue
um through the new wall that was passed
and signed just before Christmas of 2022
that allows top secret people to come
forward and speak about this issue even
though they have non-disclosure
agreements and top secret clearances so
this is something we've been working on
and advocating for for a long time it's
now enshrined in law and there's a
mechanism for these people to come
forward and one of the narratives that
people need to remember is that people
such as the co-chair of the Senate
intelligence committee Marco Rubio has
been gaslit by a number of
counterintelligence and disinformation
people who have been telling him all the
UFOs and uaps or maybe they're from
China so all of a sudden we're providing
clear evidence that these are real some
are extraterrestrial some are man-made
very classified illegal anti-gravity
propulsion systems that have been funded
through deep black funds and companies
like my uncle's company my uncle helped
design the lunar module his company was
Northrop Grumman huge Aerospace company
so I think that part of that whole
operation was a sort of a psyop
psychological warfare op and of course
the media lapped it up there were no
experts that got on that provided any
insight into this and uh the you know
hysteria and the public hysteria and the
media I think was a very calculated move
uh one of the things we've worried about
for years Danica is that at a certain
time when all this begins to come out
which is beginning to they could stay
some sort of threat from outer space
false flag operation and it sure as heck
look like a warm-up for that uh in the
past months I mean what is the potential
I feel like I mean I obviously don't run
in the same circles that you do into
that to that depth I'm just like
high-level curiosity but definitely from
like a spiritual Community perspective
there's definitely been a lot of people
that have talked about the fact that a
false flag is probably
what we're preparing for and what would
so why would they be doing a false flag
and what would the role of that be when
I heard there was those green lights I
think over Hawaii I was like oh man
drones could do that at night so easily
um so yeah to talk about the talk about
the potential of a false flag and what
they would do and why well this this
takes us back to the 50s so I have a cie
document that I got after I briefed uh
the director of the CIA on this issue in
December of 1993 so we're going back
almost 30 years
and I got a cash a box of documents from
the agency and one of them was
describing the psychological warfare
value of the UFO issue uh and it was
signed by the director of the CIA at the
time Walter Bedell Smith and it was
dated in 1953 before even I was born
never mind you so
um I was born in 55. so interestingly
what we see with this is a a 70 plus
year long-term strategy on this issue
and of course as you know the guy who
invented the rocket Freight off Hitler
Werner Von Brown and his deathbed told
his senior assistant Cheryl Rosen who's
on my team who's now in her late 70s at
the in fact this entire threat of an
alien invasion was always in the cards
starting in the 50s that they began to
hoax things and position this whole
issue Into The Lunatic Fringe of
abductions and mutilations and War of
the Worlds and the movie Independence
Day and all this crap excuse me language
but and of course this was all you know
sort of scripted out of cie covert
Central programs as a as an operation so
in reality I tell people that what we're
beginning to see ramped up
and it began after our documentary which
I know you've seen unacknowledged hit
about 760 million views worldwide wow
and when it hit that number up in that
three quarters of a billion range they
pulled the trigger on a
counterintelligence operation uh headed
up by Louise Elizondo and a few other
people who were masters of
disinformation at the Pentagon
when they roped in this young guy that I
had briefed and and mentored for a while
Tom the long and Tom Delong was the
Blink 182 guy you know and he got he got
brought in there as a front man and this
whole thing came out the the ttsa group
to the Stars Academy and they started
saying yes these are real but they're a
threat to the National Security and we
really don't know what they are well
both of those are big lies we do know
what they are and they're not a threat
to the National Security
except the ones that are ours now here's
the punch line
the ones that are the UFOs that are
man-made and that's about 70 80 percent
of the ones people see okay are in fact
a threat to the National Security
because they were they're sort of a
covert program that can be used in a
false flag just what we're talking about
and they have been it can be used to
Stage you know fake abductions and
mutilations and all kinds of scary stuff
now to what end I mean you asked this
question they want to be able to unite
the world around a sort of totalitarian
militaristic group yeah which you know
you can't do that by just fighting a few
Al-Qaeda people or one country against
another the ultimate way to do that is
you as Ronald Reagan said when he gave
his talk to the United Nations wouldn't
our job of creating uh unity and uniting
the world be easier if we had a common
alien threat to fight I'm quoting I've
seen I've seen him say that wouldn't we
come together if we knew that there was
another entity out there how how much
would we wouldn't we unite in that
exactly but instead of coming together
in peace and common humanity and
Enlightenment and higher Consciousness
and everything else we come together
around fear and militarism this is like
the one world government that is like
coming down the pipeline or that already
exists I mean the group that is running
this is a transnational
meaning it's not just in the United
States it crosses to your political
boundaries so when I go up and meet with
top secret people here in Washington
which I've been doing a great deal of
lately the first thing I tell them is
look at a map of the world
erase all the geopolitical lines they
don't exist for the group we're dealing
with it's transnational not
International and they operate with
alacrity all over the world uh and they
have enormous amounts of funding we
estimate that just out of the U.S
Hoover programs over the decades it's
around eight to ten trillion dollars
have been taken and spent on these
programs uh so it's a huge issue and a
big problem from many levels uh because
not least of which is not only is it the
future of how we view ourselves in the
universe and and whether we become a
civilization on an extinction level path
of endless war but remember that the
Technologies and go back and look at the
CNN footage
of our Navy uh F-18 Hornets chasing that
what they call the Tic Tac off the coast
of California
that white tic-tac-looking thing well by
the way that was made by the Lockheed
Skunk Works I know people who've been at
present when it's been loaded on C-130
cargo planes it's ours it's anti-gravity
what does it mean it's an
electromagnetic field propulsion and if
that were acknowledged it would be the
end of oil gas Co nuclear power solar
wind geothermal all of it so uh now
people need to understand what a big
statement that is it means that we have
about a hundred years where we haven't
needed to destroy the biosphere or had
half the world in poverty but the power
around the Petro dollar system from
after World War II Bretton Woods the
power around all those Commodities and
all the corporate structures your public
utilities
all of that is something we don't need
frankly actually we're going to have a
movie a full-length feature film coming
out soon called The Lost Century
how to how to regain it uh the subtitles
how to regain it and we just finished it
we hope it comes out June July this year
and it's going to be a two-hour feature
film it's going to pull the curtain back
on all of this to the public so it seems
like this might be a silly question but
it seems like there's so many people
that are potentially getting quite old
that are part of this
control group
does that
bode well for us that the powers will be
transitioning that or or will it not or
or or do we need to worry about someone
like a Elon Musk or you know who is it
that it is that we need to worry about
and do you think that the transition is
happening into something else because
it's been going on for essentially like
a generation it's been going on for uh
about four generations
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen